hey guys i'm ryan right and III is
continuing and they have a new trailer
out for tomb raider now I'll admit I am
NOT the biggest tomb raider fan I did
not give a [ __ ] about it Laura Croft
though superhot my anxiety is going in
and I am getting penis horny right now
just thinking about her character and
actually Jolie was hot as Laura Croft I
heard the second one sucked that movie
and I didn't really care about the first
one that was kind of boring but yeah I'm
excited to see this new trailer right
here it's supposed to be like the reboot
of the franchise so maybe this is
something I want to hop on board let's
find out shall we like tits
I think we're making progress in these
sessions all right we say the flashbacks
have stopped I like therapy stuff
this is excellent improvement but I'm
concerned that you're still shutting
yourself away oh no it's important
it looks really cool
Oh dad nah
is crossed
she's [ __ ] fine Superman's lair
that's what she just found found it
um that looks really [ __ ] cool man
I mean I I'm pretty stoked to play that
game I'm not that familiar with it but
if the tone of the movie clip is at all
like what the gameplay is I imagine the
gameplay would have a real kind of
mystery vibe about it trying to solve a
puzzle and you know strategize and [ __ ]
just like how I strategize my way no
woman's Jenna is that the throw sex joke
in there I just couldn't go a video
without doing one yeah I'll definitely
play that game man I'm gonna I'm buying
like a lot of these games you guys don't
realize I'm gonna get super into video
games now well anyway guys yeah if
you're new to the channel see this
button up here you can click it and you
can subscribe subscribe please please
subscribe I mean they mean a lot to me
go out could have fun buy each other
cookies [ __ ] then go to Chuck E Cheese
it's okay if we go to Chuck E Cheese and
we're not horny and we're surrounded by
children and we are appropriate adults
now before I get into the shoutouts I
just want to mention a girl and Natalia
samoilova dude this girl said on one of
my videos see I like to reply back in
order of comments that came in just to
be fair but occasionally I get crazed to
breeze through a few other comments
Natalya Simonova said Ryan I always love
your reactions right away I saw this
woman's thumbnail and I was like whoa
she's [ __ ] cute so like the normal
guy I am I decided to go on her YouTube
page and she had a link to her Facebook
and Instagram being more normal I
decided to click on these links and I
saw her Facebook page and it wasn't like
a personal Facebook page it was like an
actress Facebook page and she's an
actress and she's really [ __ ] hot
damn I want to get to know you better
inside and out you know this is why I
get friend-zoned
Stevi see he said you two are freaking
hilarious any chance I can get a shout
out well he got it man
when he said you - he was a friend -
ELISA and I and ELISA and I were being
right now just say you know I want
everyone to know that if she asks and
denies she's a goddamn liar
we have sex all the time what's up baby
hey doing don't bring that vagina over
here be a Stevie see III like you you
you have good respect for the right
people thank you John Monahan
he said shoutout discovered this channel
when you guys reviewed the Ray - still
my movie of the year so far been a fan
ever since
wow that was a while back man so John
Monahan thank you dude you've been
around for a while you're cool to you
Monahan
Michelle Monaghan on a mana I'm on a
high in on God you say it I'm huggin and
she's cute too damn I would lick those
nipples Rob stooge shoutout big fan huh
I this isn't how I imagined all you guys
say your [ __ ] so yeah that's he had a
bunch of exclamation marks he's a big
fan Rob's tears I like you you you're a
fan of me chew on my autograph how they
get your autograph Eminem said it's a
soldier